I
am guilty of stacking my dishes in the
sink and leaving him there for hours I
fact checked this with my boyfriend he
says it's less like hours and more like
days but that's not the point the point
is sometimes I don't finish the job
until the stack has gotten high enough
that it's peeking over the lip of the
sink and my inner clean freak loses it
this charming habit developed when I was
in college and I had tons of excuses I'm
running to class what's one more dirty
dish in the sink or my favorite I think
I could save time and water if I do them
all together later
but it's not like I needed those excuses
cuz nobody was calling me on it I wish
they had I look back now and realized
that every time I didn't put a dish in
the dishwasher and finish what I started
it became more second nature to me and I
grew less likely to question why I was
doing it today I'm a 30-something
certified dirty dish lever and breaking
this habit is hard
so when I'm not at home avoiding the
sink I work with large complex
organizations on leadership
transformation and times of change my
job is to work with the most senior
leaders to examine how they lead today
and establish habits better suited for
the future but what interests me more
than senior leaders these days is what's
going on with the junior ones we call
them middle managers but it's a term I
wish we could change because what they
are is our pipeline of future talent for
the c-suite and they are starting to
leave their dishes in the sink while
organizations are hiring people like me
to redevelop their senior leaders for
the future outdated leadership habits
are forming right before our eyes among
the middle managers who will one day
take their place
we need middle managers and senior
leaders to work together because this is
a big problem
organizations are evolving rapidly and
they're counting on their future leaders
to lead with more speed flexibility
trust in cooperation than they do today
I
believe there is a window of time in the
formative middle manager years when we
can lay the groundwork for that kind of
leadership but we're missing it why
because our future leaders are learning
from senior role models who just aren't
ready to role model yet much less
changed the systems that made them so
successful
we need middle managers and senior
leaders to work together to define a new
way of leading and develop each other to
rise to the occasion
one of my favorite senior clients will
call her Jane is a poster child for
what's old-fashioned and leadership
today she rose to her sea level position
based on exceptional individual
performance come hell or high water Jane
got the job done and today she leads
like it she is tough to please she
doesn't have a lot of time for things
that aren't mission-critical and she
really doesn't trust anyone's judgment
more than her own needless to say Jane's
in behavior boot camp those deeply
ingrained habits are deeply inconsistent
with where her organization is heading
the command and control behavior that
she was once rewarded for just isn't
going to work in a faster-moving flatter
more digitally interconnected
organization what got her here won't get
her there
but I want to talk about John a super
talented up-and-coming manager who works
for Jane because her habits are rubbing
off on him
recently he and I were strategizing
about a decision we needed to put in
front of the CEO Jane's boss and the
rest of Jane's peers he said to me Liz
you're not gonna like this but the way
decisions get made around here is with a
bunch of meetings before the meeting I
counted that was going to mean eight
one-on-ones exact by exec to make sure
each one of them was individually
onboard enough that things would go
smoothly in the actual meeting
he promised it's not how we'll do things
in the future but it's how we have to do
them today
John wasn't wrong on either count
meetings before the meeting are a
necessary evil in his company today and
I didn't like it at all sure it was
going to be inefficient and annoying but
what bothered me most was his confidence
that it's not how they'll do things in
the future
how could he be sure
who was going to change it and when if
it wasn't him and now
what would the trigger be and when it
happened would he even know how to have
effective meetings without pre meetings
he was confidently implying that when
he's the boss he'll change the rules and
do things differently but all I could
see were dishes stacking in the sink and
a guy with a lot of good excuses worse a
guy who might be out of a job one day
because he learned too late how to lead
in the organizations of tomorrow
these stories really get to me when it's
the fast-track high potential managers
like John because they're probably the
most capable of making waves and
redefining how leaders lead from the
inside but what we find is that they're
often doing the best job at not rocking
the boat and challenging the system
because they're trying to impress and
make life easier on the senior leaders
who will promote them as someone who
also likes to get promoted I can hardly
blame him it's a catch-22
but they're also so self assured that
they'll be able to change their behavior
once they've earned the authority to do
things differently and that is a trap
because if I've learned anything from
working with Jane it's that when that
day comes John will wonder how he could
possibly do anything differently in his
high-stakes high-pressure executive job
without risking his own success and the
organization's and he'll wish it didn't
feel so safe and so easy to keep doing
things the way they've always been done
so the leadership development expert in
me asks how can we better intervene in
the formative years of our soon-to-be
senior leaders how can we use the fact
that John and his peers want to take
charge of their professional destinies
and get them ready to leave the
organizations of the future rather than
let them succumb to the catch-22 that
will perfectly prepare them to lead the
organizations of the past
we'll have to start by coming to terms
with a very real paradox which is this
the best form of learning happens on the
job not in a classroom not via Emil's
and the two things we rely on to shape
on-the-job learning are role models and
work environments and as we just talked
about our role models are in behavior
boot camp right now and our work
environments are undergoing
unprecedented disruption we are
systematically changing just about
everything about how organizations work
but by and large still measuring and
rewarding behavior based on old metrics
because changing those systems takes
time so if we can't fully count on role
models or the system right now it's on
John to not miss this critical
development window yes he'll need Jane's
help to do it but the responsibility is
his because the risks are actually his
either he inherits an organization that
is failing because of stubbornly
old-fashioned leadership or he himself
fails to build the capabilities to lead
one that transformed while he was
playing it safe
so now the question is where does John
start if I were John I'd ask to start
flying the plane
for my 13th birthday my grandpa a former
Navy pilot gave me the gift of being
able to fly a very small plane
once we were safely airborne the pilot
turned over the controls folded his
hands and he let me fly
it was totally terrifying it was
exhilarating but it was also on-the-job
learning with a safety net and because
it was real I really learned how to do
it myself
likewise in the workplace every meeting
to be led every decision to be made can
be a practice flight for someone who
could really use the learning experience
and the chance to figure out how to do
it their own way so instead of caving
John needs to knock on Jane's door
propose a creative strategy for having
the meeting without the eight
pre-meetings shower he's thought through
the trade-offs and asked for her support
to do it differently
this isn't going to be easy for Jane not
only does she need to trust John she
needs to accept that with a little bit
of room to try his hand at leading John
will inevitably start leading in some
ways that are far more John
than Jane and this won't be an
indictment of her rather it will be
individualism it will be progress and it
might even be a chance for Jane to learn
a thing or two to take her own
leadership game to the next level I
work with another senior client who
summed up this dilemma beautifully when
we were talking about why he and his
peers haven't empowered the folks below
them with more decision rights he said
haven't done it because we just don't
trust that they're going to make the
right decisions but then again how could
they we've just never given them
decisions to practice with so
I'm not advocating that Jane hands over
the controls and folds her hands
indefinitely but what I am saying is
that if she doesn't engineer learning
and practice right into John's day today
he'll never be able to do what she does
much less do it any differently than she
does it
finally since we're gonna be pushing
both of them outside their comfort zones
we need some outside coaches to make
sure this isn't a case of the blind
leading the blind but what if instead of
using coaches to coach each one of them
to individually be more effective we
started coaching the interactions
between them if I could wave my magic
wand I would have coaches sitting in the
occasional team meeting of Jane and her
direct reports debriefing solely on how
well they cooperated that day I would
put a coach in the periodic feedback
session between Jane and John and just
like a couples therapist coaches on
communication they would offer advice
and observations on how that
conversation can go better in the future
was Jane simply reinforcing what Jane
would have done or was Jane really
helping John think through what to do
for the organization that is seriously
hard mentorship to provide and even the
best leaders need help doing it which is
why we need more coaches coaching more
leaders more in real-time versus any one
leader behind closed doors
around 20 years ago Warren Buffett gave
a school lecture in which he said the
chains of habit are too light to be felt
until they're too heavy to be broken I
couldn't agree more
and I see it happening with our future
leaders in training can we and they be
doing more to build their leadership
capabilities while they're still open
eager and not too far gone down a path
of bad habits we totally saw coming I
wish my college roommates and I had
called each other out back then for the
dishes it would have been so much easier
to nip that have it in the bud than it
is to change it today but I still
believe in a future for myself full of
gleaming sinks and busy dishwashers and
so we're working on it every day
together moment to moment one dirty dish
at a time thank you
[Applause]
[Music]